it's a bell fed that shoots five five
six but the CQB version where the the
stock is collapsible but that's not a
privately owned you can't own one yeah
probably the other one probably no Mark
49 is what it's called so you wish you
wish you could have one personally
absolutely well Tron you're a boy
[Music]
welcome back to our very special episode
of the careful boys where we have with
us three very distinguished gentlemen
wow right here we have three members of
different specials
all right now
[Applause]
that's all we wanted I know so um Sam's
angels we released a a little opening
for all of our Instagram followers to be
able to ask them some questions and
um we're gonna go ahead and start with
Bart with Bart's opening questions let's
start with the relatable one yeah we'll
start with one that's relatable then
we'll go off the reels because everyone
knows when you're in the military you
have to masturbate in weird places
so going down the road what is the
weirdest place you guys masturbated and
we'll start with
um first appointment in a um Hut so like
30 something dudes with cots next to
each other yeah that's what we were
sleeping in yeah yeah you know and can
get lonely yeah I heard that's pretty
calm and got to you don't have any
privacy whatsoever and you know you just
do it in from
in your sleeping bag with 30 guys around
yeah and are they like ah Don's doing it
again
off
[Laughter]
classic Don and everyone just
understands because everyone understands
yeah sure you're in the same boat right
you gotta get some release
uh I don't know how weird it is because
when you do it every day for like seven
months it's just like normal but what do
you think back you're like that was kind
of weird I'll let you guys decide but I
probably spent seven months jerking off
in a porta potty
nice that's nice it's considering I
prefer my privacy than this guy yeah how
come he's a decent human being why are
you so classy
every time he goes first
either aims too high
the thing is the thing you have to
realize though is uh in those places
that we've been at War even at night
it's like 105 degrees outside and the
temperature inside a porta potty the
smells inside a porta potty at 120
degrees it's like a song it's like a
steam room yeah yeah yeah
but when you're a horny man with high
stroke got it I get it out but the
Privacy is probably worth it though so
worth it yeah no regrets
I did the same thing he did but the
fumes from the [__] [__] and the
urine so bad because this obviously does
it doesn't run I grab my [__] gas
mask I threw that [__] on and I'm
trying
is it like full kit like take the AR off
put it here and then or is it like you
you go there and like PT I was in my PT
I had my AR but I brought my [__] gas
mask so I place it right in the corner
[__] die my gas mask did my [__] real
quick then just [__] went yeah cool
efficient yeah wow all right now we got
some from our followers Jeffy who would
like to know did any of you ever tap the
barracks bunny what is that what is that
what does that mean it sounds like yeah
having sex with a girl that's also a
part of the military yeah right or maybe
just a girl that like is visiting with
one guy and maybe oh that sounds like a
she comes with one guy but then leaves
with you
or no I've seen a lot of the situation
at the barracks like that or recall I
think we call it Barrett's rat maybe or
something oh like a hood wrap a Barracks
rat like a lot lizard it's like a
positive connotation to it well because
she's dirty you know I mean she's going
around running around every room which
is a rat yeah right yeah this is real
this is another real question Danny
Nguyen asks do you think that just being
a marine like Bart is some [__] [__]
damn
well let's go with this dude that's my
burger count
let's go with Trump first
uh no I think you I respect all service
members you guys are all awesome he's so
nice you know what the funniest thing is
that like what I noticed is like from
higher level guys they just don't do
that whole my company right it's the
best company
and then from the guys that'll over
level they all fight like that how about
this hey Aiden asks if you if all three
of you were left in one room with a
knife who's walking out of that room
yeah do you guys want to try yeah yeah
we don't know each other that's so hard
yeah only one way to find out
based on First Impressions yeah yeah can
I interrupt real quick and just say tell
me you're a ranger without telling me
you're a ranger
this guy's phone case oh
[__]
okay that's a good one you would win The
Knife Fight what would what is like the
stereotypical thing you think about each
other's like a job that's a great
question like a lot of people that go
like
um like let's say there's like a high
security clearance area you see a guy in
a Hawaiian shirt that's the seal you
know like was there like a what's the
stereotypical thing you guys think of
each other
I I gotta brace myself for what these
guys
for sales good hair great hair with gel
holy [__] look at all that Bart when you
watch it I was like this is the team guy
yeah how did you know because when you
walked in how did you know that just
just the way his demeanor so seals look
like like because my best friend on team
one he's like almost like but he has
tattoo obviously but he has slick hair
back and he's like this is like oh
there's like himself great hair is a
prerequisite
Jacob is a seal right yeah he does he
have him he doesn't have no hair yeah
but maybe he didn't
what do you think of the other two
around you
I mean you guys eat crayons for surgery
yeah I give you a compliment
is it untrue yeah yeah that's fair so
like Marines are [__] no they just
literally eat crayons
[Laughter]
there's two questions and they literally
both say what's your favorite flavor of
Crayola
so that's a real that's a real like
running joke what is the thing about
marines that make them so [__] to
other people it's Marines are [__]
uh I I just I just every time my Marine
buddies are around I always make that
crying joke
he does and then right you know I gotta
say this yeah for sure Rangers lead the
way always that's just all the
[__] ways
that's good and bad like lead the way
it's a positive and negative
yeah yeah they're always taking
jurisdiction all right Carrie Damien
wants to know who eats the most out of
your three divisions like who can eat
the most eat the most food yeah he's all
scared he's like crazy ass or food or
what whatever but he's like before I
answer it before I go first
I don't know that's a really random
question no correlation specific special
ops that's like oh they're known for it
they'll eat [__] everything or
everyone's just hungry well the Navy
Chow Halls are the most disgusting it's
like prison food so I would say it's
probably not us really really so you
weren't getting lobster and steak
probably this guy yeah there we go we
get we get all you we get all you can
eat and the chefs they're [__]
awesome they make good food yeah so you
get lobster and steak but they don't
they probably do no so that's overseas I
sell them how overseas uh on Friday
Saturday and Sunday they will serve us
lobster and steak Yeah and all the bad
news was coming yeah
oh flemen's getting extended lobster and
steak that's nice so uh Giovanni wants
to know if you had to choose like you've
got to pick one what country would you
fight
I think what country is not going to
send people to my house right uh
definitely don't want to fight China
really well I mean it's just any war
with any major country would be yeah
should show for people at home and
um true over there so you want to fight
one that's like just take them out the
one second I mean there's no war like
that anymore you know it's like
everything is like guerrilla warfare and
all that stuff so every war is going to
be complicated no matter what so they
don't have like the wars like World War
II style where they just D-Day like line
up and then everyone charge like is it
all like more covert kind of [__]
yeah it's like everything is like
working with another creation or partner
force or something to like Ukraine right
now like that yeah drones I'm not saying
that we are in Ukraine right I got a
question and you guys can't copy each
other
if you had a hostage
and you need to get answers out of them
okay wait answers out of the hostage you
have a high value Target
[Laughter]
because the hostage is on our side
usually right yeah but you're not you're
not allowed to use violence
only sexual advances wow
squeal
start with you Don
ate see if they're ticklish first so you
go like where are the rest of the guys
at and then you tickle them I can't yeah
start with that that's kind of nice and
you think that would work I can so it
does say it didn't work now what do you
do
first
[Laughter]
are there honey pot operations like yes
like we're they actually try to use hot
spies to get you guys to like
get give information and all that stuff
or like the us on this side too yeah
they do that bro it's difficult when a
beautiful woman is trying to be like
tell me the secrets if you're like okay
I'll tell you everything just let's do
it just give it up let's do it there's a
young man so old asks have you ever used
any movie phrases while on a mission oh
my God like I'll be back or some [__] a
little die hard yeah
no but I've always wanted to say I'm a
Navy SEAL and I'm here to get you out
that's pretty sad Charlie Sheen but uh
no I've never just didn't have enough
time in the moment because things are
too chaotic I had to think of the
mission
slips your mind in the moment when it's
crazy yeah it's like Archer where like
you think of it afterwards you're like
oh I should have said that yeah yeah oh
yeah perfect moment here's here's kind
of a tough one from the same guy he said
have you ever found yourself missing the
action more than your family oh
yes
yeah because it like fuels you or it's
like a it's like a level of stimulation
that is hard to replace or there's no
adrenaline like a getting in a gunfight
well you're kind of scared kind of not
kind of excited
kind of lonely
yeah I think my thought was always like
this is what I was born for and as long
as my kids are taken care of they're
gonna be okay
but I'm needed here
yeah that's pretty crazy are you guys
still like um in military or no no how
was that like if if you felt like that
was your world and that's what you were
meant to do and because most special op
guys retire younger in life right like
you can't really do it into your late
40s 50s and on
so
um
did you have a plan for after the
military
I did not
um my yeah I wanted to be a seal since I
was a kid and then so getting out was
like super hard I see really hard so you
specifically
um you went through Buds and then you're
also a buds instructor yeah yeah so
seeing it from the other side
um and also being an instructor did that
give you like what kind of insight did
you gain from like
being able to see it from the other side
and also like are there any like tips or
pieces of advice that you could give to
people the people that are going through
it or wanting to go through it
yeah I think I think what I got to see
was uh behind the curtain on the process
that the instructors
were trying their best to create the
best product
but the bureaucracy from above like way
above not like directly above but way
above was trying to just get as many
people through regardless of of ability
or qualification and just trying to
water down the talent
uh and there's this constant battle
and I think my advice to anyone going
through that training and that this goes
for all this is like don't make your
goal to get through the training don't
don't try to like oh I'm gonna get
through buds I'm gonna get through ITC
like
think like stretch that goal out 10
years 20 years and be like I want to be
the best operator I can be
because the training was what two years
of your entire career
a year to like depending it fluctuates
but that was like a very small amount of
like somebody's 20-year career and
everyone's so hyper focused on like oh I
just got to get through buds I got to
get through Buds and then it's over it's
just the [__] beginning
yeah what do people typically do after
um special ops like do they stay in the
military and then do other jobs in the
military or like what's like a lot of
your guys is like
homies comrades
I'm in you go be an instructor like Mike
was like so you're not you know you're
still
um an operator but you're not actually
in the teams uh you can go to like
leadership positions you can do and
there's a bunch of other jobs that you
can do
outside do most people stay in the
military and then like continue their
careers like until
um like you know way into 60s and stuff
no so I mean most guys probably if they
were staying their full 20 they'd get
out at 20 because you can get a pension
from the military so you could typically
retire in like your 30s or how how old
would you be when you're yeah
technically yeah wow like 38 yeah wow
because if you do 20 years not enough
for you to actually
you know live a full life or anything
but it's a good pension still I mean
some guys do 30 like officers and [__]
right like it depends everybody has
their limit on when they stop chasing
the dragon I call it chasing the dragon
you know everybody has their limits like
how many tours or how many years they do
everybody's different some stay some
move want to go on and join the unit or
go go to damn neck and be enjoying you
know go through Green Team and try to
become SEAL Team Six or you know further
their career in there others they did
their time they did what they wanted to
do they wanted to get out and they want
to do something else
it really varies on the the individual
really for each of you guys like what
was uh the hardest moment that you've
experienced that made
that potentially would have made you
quit or made you even think about
putting in training in training or
afterwards just like what was like the
hardest moment you encountered during
like the Special Operations time hmm
I think the hardest moment in training
for me was like
every Tuesday morning
because every Tuesday morning you woke
up and you're like
it's 4 a.m yesterday was the hardest
[__] day of my life they make Mondays
the hardest no it just every day is the
hardest [__] day of your life
[Laughter]
yesterday was the hardest day of my life
today's Tuesday it's going to be the
hardest day of my life and I have
another year of this yeah assuming I
make it it's a year training if you make
it through clean which like five percent
of people do it's a year of training
what's what's clean like like without
injury illness or like performance like
getting set back and having to redo so
like for instance I got illness and uh
well I guess injury so illness and
injury separately and I saw attack on
like another four to six months you have
to get recycled oh yeah and that's like
a very standard that's not unique does
recycle mean start from the beginning
yeah oh or or like from a different
phases yeah the beginning of the phase
that you're at so you're oh damn you
start the game over yeah that's like a
Nintendo
we keep dropping at the last spot yeah
so you have a save game save the game
yeah P Naval asks what's the worst
punishment you ever had to do
[__] where do I begin
I would say uh one night we got Hayes uh
some other [__] uh senior guys got
[__] pretty wasted and that is hug
[__] trees upside down so you're
upside down
I forgot the name of it we they make us
[__] jumpsuit tree and basically
[__] hold it upside down and whoever
let goes for us gets continuous smoking
so we just [__] have to sit there and
play this game of hold on for your dear
[__] life
[Laughter]
you're like literally holding this
[__] tree upside down like this
that's pretty gangster dude
because some of the guys were drunk they
were drunk and they you know hazing back
then is different now you know I mean
back then they would they hazed the [__]
out of us so we just took it what about
what about you
um
I was that Iraq on my first appointment
and I fell asleep in the back of the
truck like on a patrol
so when we got back they made me fill a
Hesco bear which is like uh if you
imagine like a chain link fence uh and
like Fabric in between it but we need to
fill it with a MRE spoon oh my God 120
degrees out so you just [__] like
that yeah I mean of course when they
weren't looking I was like
four days
all right
[__] Jesus it's miserable never fell
asleep again
I bet well you must have been tired
yeah I mean they let me sleep at night
you know oh that's nice were you like
it's like a road trip it's all
comfortable in the back dude it's so hot
in there you know it's like it's so hard
to stay awake yeah what about you Mike
um since you've been an instructor
hardest punishment you got and the
hardest punishment yeah
I I think that for me doing it I don't I
don't know if I have any like crazy
story it was just all awful
um
but I I had some pretty good [__] up
ones to students
[Laughter]
just take it on me it was just me alone
and nobody else and they don't condone
this and I just broke all Navy violation
by doing this
I don't give a [__] uh
we had a student who had uh
it was a good one we had a student who
was like pretty arrogant and you know
it's frowned upon to just beat the [__]
out of him so
he gave him a pot I gave him a pot
and uh
he had to run to the ocean which was
about 100 yards
he had to run to the ocean scoop up a
mouth of ocean water run it back and
dump it
and fill up the pot oh that's Savage
please
wow salt water this [__] mouth wow
[Music]
so the the funny thing was I thought
this was funny it was after like
10 15 laps you know you're running 100
yards in soft sand and you're wet and
cold and uh he this student
um you know what do you start doing you
have to breathe heavily and maybe dry
heaves so it started like don't do it
and then he might dry heat it up and
then have to go back
uh outcome of the lesson
one of the most humble dudes after that
wow wow that's cool and I don't care
what anyone says oh that's too hard you
[__] ride it's hard but you're trying
to develop the hardest people on the
planet and that's how you do it right
yeah it was awful I'm sure it was awful
but that didn't sound like abuse to me
that sounds like it's like it's a good
way to teach and it's comedic
yeah but it's like how people perceive
it you know oh the people perceive
things so weird now yeah I'm only but
that's why you're not maybe sealed
though you know yeah I'm only putting
myself in the shoes of the guy that did
it right because I mean like I said a
lot of stupid [__] as a as a youngster
and then like I probably talked back to
a lot of people and if someone made me
do that I think I would have been like
serves me right but you know what Mike
up end up doing I I see it this way as
Mike ended up saving that dude's
character you know now he knows how to
be [__] humble and I bet you he
brought that all the way for the rest of
his career all into his life yeah
because big picture wise I think
arrogance can get people killed right
because you're overconfident you think
you know everything and then you're just
like
not even
considering everything I don't know that
just sounds like you probably did yeah
save his life so we um here's another
question uh from young man he said have
have you ever found yourself triggered
by a memory sound or action and it it
put you in like a rage
like a mood where you felt like
aggressive
mean like fear and anxiety more than
rage like what is an experience or is it
like a sound or a trigger or
um anything specific or I remember
coming back from Afghanistan my first
time I just had like social anxiety
couldn't be around people I remember
going to a mall with my ex-girlfriend at
the time and there's just so much people
around like I had a fake that I had a
phone call to go outside to take it like
a lot of people was bothering you yeah
is it because of just like there's so
much going on or I don't know why oh
it's just don't it's unexplainable yeah
it's switching environments too fast and
stuff
uh I think for me like large crowds like
overwhelming the large crowds I remember
one of my first years out I came up to
LA and there was like a firework show
and every [__] human in Los Angeles
went to this fireworks show and in five
minutes the and the noise going off I
was like I'm out and I just left I was
like not happening
um it's it's not I it's hard to say
you're not like oh the memories it's
it's just more like
I see this turning South real fast you
know whether that's like one guy with a
gun or you know you're thinking like
what could happen if this was a war zone
even though it's not a war zone and yeah
run away that makes sense yeah you just
probably see threats like more than the
average person because of what you win
is like for me I would see a football
game and then you can see like oh [__]
like this is too vulnerable but you're
also like trained to just identify those
things yeah throughout your career and
your past because you have to be but
yeah I'm just looking at the mascot at
the game dancing and [__] you guys you
know this is dangerous
we got the cheerleaders
did you have any I would say the noises
and stuff never affected me but leaving
the military what I told you guys about
my first year back when I was just like
a recruiter hermit I think that's that
affected me that way you know what I
mean like I I had to be alone with my
inner demons trying to cope with alcohol
and you know having no one to talk to
the outlet or anything like that that
was my PTSD so uh Mr Jack PP we're gonna
end it on a nice one what's your
favorite gun
pistol rifle type that's a possible
question any specific type they just
said gun
all right uh in a gunfight outside
outdoor still still too tough huh he's
like what's the distance yeah what's the
situation
in this parking lot outside
you guys got rollerblades on well yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah what's the what's
the ideal Target is on the scooters six
grenade shooter oh yeah
whatever it is or the thumper the m79
yeah yeah
what's that automatic shotgun from John
Wick oh dude the H is that the a12 yeah
it's like whatever that new one is I'll
tell you if I have rollerblades that's
what I want
why a shotgun over like the AR rep
because that one in the movie and I
forget the brand somebody will figure it
out it's basically like an AR rifle oh
the AR platform but AR platform with
shotgun rounds like with a magazine yeah
loaded oh oh yeah yeah I know you're
talking about yeah I would take that
yeah because on Rollerblades you're
gonna miss a whole lot with a shotgun
exactly all right last question all
right all right uh have you guys ever
fell in love with a Target like you
don't know movies like they're guys you
got a Target and then you get there
you're like I can't
yeah you run away or whatever
yeah
are you sure are you sure
no I don't know about these guys
anything close to that I'll ask her
about the gun
though I hate carrying it when I was in
the military I [__] would love to
have it again as the mark 249. yeah
yeah what's that it's a belt fed that
shoots five five six but the CQB version
where the the stock is collapsible
you're just [__] laying down hey is
that me can we get one oh [__] Bro oh my
goodness just gotta you get a little
backwards yeah somebody braced me I
don't know I'm a big fan you can't get
that anywhere uh range in Vegas it's
expensive but you can but but that's not
a privately owned you can't own one yeah
probably the other one probably no Mark
49 is what it's called that's the uh the
baby version kind of um
so you wish you wish you could have one
personally absolutely well Tron you're a
boy
[Laughter]
well thank you guys for sharing yeah
thanks for answering all our fans
questions
[Applause]